hello and welcome to the debate on Sky
News I'm Anna Jones here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
gun owners responsible gun owners
hunters form a different organization
and take back the Second Amendment from
these extremists mass shootings and
child victims should the president be
taking executive action on gun control
and Donald Trump's vow is not a quitter
he's going all the way and he's going to
win
President Barack Obama has made gun
control his top priority and the three
leading Democratic presidential
candidates have injected renewed vigor
in their push for restrictions that said
Republicans and the NRA continue their
mantra the only way to stop a bad guy
with a gun is with a good guy with a gun
so is it well as you shall be democratic
commentator Jeffrey Robinson is in New
York Forrest and the conservative
commentator Armstrong Williams is in
Washington so welcome to both of you as
for Williams to you first of all 11
year-old suspected of shooting dead an
eight-year-old the Oregon shootings
leaving 8 dead is it time for gun laws
to be reviewed in the u.s. is Hillary
Clinton right you know you must respect
human life and there's no question when
you hear the story of 11 year old
shooting another child to death with the
gun is heart-wrenching but you know
unfortunately Anna these stories are not
new what we see in Oregon is not new it
is becoming routine in the United States
and and and this will continue to happen
if so on decides to get a firearm and go
out and want to create a massacre
because they have mental illness or
they're terrorists there's very little
you can do it now you may be able to
minimize it by having well trained
security guards on the premises and that
becomes an expense for the universities
and high schools that sometimes cannot
afford it it's not in their budget but
passing more legislation we've had this
debate before I don't and even if you
look at the Democratic candidates
certainly candidate Bernie Sanders is
not where mrs. Clinton is he believes
that you should limit it in background
checks but he's also been a very strong
supporter a much of the NRA legislation
through his career in the Senate I
understand that mrs. Clinton is on the
campaign trail and I'm sure she's
outraged as we all are by the senseless
violence at Oregon but we have to count
about wheels and see what we can do to
keep illegal guns out of the hands of
people who would commit these kind of
crimes and do a better job of vetting
these young people for mental illness
before they commit these crimes
Jeffrey what do you make of it I mean is
anything likely to change with
Republicans unlikely to back anything
will there be any kind of reform well
you see the Republican argument you know
arm the good guys would be when the
eleven year old goes to shoot the eight
year old if the eight year old had a gun
he wouldn't have gotten killed I mean it
is a completely wacko delusional
ignorant stupid argument especially
because the Republicans and the NRA
especially the NRA the leadership of the
NRA not the members because the members
want legislation but the leadership of
the NRA miss states the Second Amendment
all the time now when the Second
Amendment was first proposed in 1789 it
read the right of the people to keep and
bear Arms shall not be infringed
semicolon a well-armed and
well-regulated militia being the best
security of a free country and then
there was an interesting clause that
said but no person religiously
scrupulous of bearing arms shall be
compelled to render military service in
person so the Second Amendment when it
was proposed was originally talking
about a militia and bearing arms as part
of an army now it was then revised and
they took out or they added after a
regulated militia composed of the body
of the people again referring to an army
when it came before Congress to be
ratified it was reduced to they took the
the conscientious objector status out
and it was reduced to the twenty seven
words that it is today
but the original version that was put
before Congress capitalize the word
militia again
a reference to a standing army the NRA
believes that it refers to anybody
bearing arms to protect themselves as
opposed to an army and when at last came
up before the Supreme Court Justice
Scalia in his idiotic rule against the
city of Washington to have regulated
guns completely disregarded the the
first half of the clause about a
well-regulated militia and the words
well-regulated are still there that's
what we need is well regulation okay
well that's why you to stand let's bring
in an expert now Charles Gallagher is
professor of sociology at LaSalle
University in Philadelphia a child
Galaga good to talk to you
grisly statistics coming out in the wake
of this terrible shooting in Oregon in
which eight people died including one
statistic that suggests that there are
more guns than people in America at the
moment how do people react to mass
shootings and hearing figures like that
the people want tighter controls or do
they want looser controls on guns most
people in the United States absolutely
want more gun control and I say if you
look at the statistics people that own
guns 87% of all gun owners want more
background checks unfortunately talking
about the NRA has such undue influence
on politicians particularly Republicans
because they're terrified that they will
lose a tiny part of the constituency and
in races especially national elections
people win by very small margins I think
what needs to happen is this need to be
reframed as a public health issue and
this is simply what it is and the
government has the ability there's a
famous line that state ways can change
folk ways and by that they mean even
though the government through public
policy can change culture and you can
look at slavery as a woman's right to
vote interracial marriage no gay
marriage after a generational - it
becomes normative think about drunk
driving laws their new seatbelt laws
they're new
having a sin tax on cigarettes that's
new and it changed behavior what we mean
in which we do not have is the political
will to do it
we have spineless Democrats we have
Republicans that are completely
pandering to a tiny fringe of their
party until we have people stand up and
say this is a public health issue we are
not going to move forward at all it's
gonna be gridlock
how do people act do they actually think
well if there is gonna be some kind of
change if there's gonna be a clamp down
I'll go and get myself a gun now and
look how dangerous it is out there we
see mass shootings I need to protect
myself yes so mass shootings Julianne
you know what happened courses is
horrible but if you look at the way that
these guns are used handguns the number
one use of it is suicide and then it's
homicide and those homicides are
typically people that know one another
mass shootings in terms of total amount
of shootings per year is miniscule and
the fact is the United States is safer
now that it's everything the real
problem you see there's one gun for
every person that stinks really isn't
food it's one person having 14 guns one
person having 22 guns these are people
that really are typically unstable so
most people the United States aren't
walking around armed to the teeth scare
what we have is basically a very very
strong small lobbying body that's able
to convince Congress and the United
States that the world is dangerous and
then an eight-year-old needs a gun every
kindergarten teacher should have a gun
I'm a teacher I don't want my students
to have guns in the classroom
I don't think propels guns it's simply
nonsense and until we get some
politicians are gonna spell it out and
Hillary Clinton you know she's pander
you know she's playing it down the
center it's opportunism all the way
she's not proposing anything that's new
we are just spinning our wheels and she
weeks from now I'm not talking not
working it'll be back to normal so
answer on what do you make of that let's
let's talk about the background checks
that Hillary Clinton is talking about
making tighter that there is this
strange anomaly isn't there where people
can buy guns online or a gun shows
without the same kind of background
checks
shouldn't that be changed you know it is
reasonable with these private gun owners
sellers that they just don't sell
someone a gun immediately on the spot
without Lisa 10 of 15 and maybe a 30-day
background check and record their
history their profile I mean that is
absolutely reasonable if you look at
what happened in Charleston South
Carolina and there's families and passed
a Pinckney died in that church for no
reason at all
this kid was before and they had an
opportunity to really VOC I'm giving him
the gun and somehow another with
everything in place he still it was able
to get through his system and he was a
granted the license so even sometimes
Ana when the systems in place and
everything is in order with the
guidelines sometimes law enforcement and
the vetting process don't do their job
and they still slip through the system
I think it's so disingenuous of the
professor to make it seem as though it
is Republicans a spirit number of
Republicans are the reasons why this
issue will never change of course is the
Republicans who do you think it is I
mean if the Republicans voted for
sensible gun legislation it was the
Republicans who repealed the Brady Act I
mean the idea that you can walk down the
street with the coalition a cop it's
ridiculous of course it's the
Republicans pandering to the NRA and
again the NRA has got the second
amendment wrong now in the city of New
York where I am it's really really
really hard to buy a gun you have to go
through all sorts of Hoops to do it
however you can go down a Virginian to a
gun show buy one at a gun show put in
your pocket and drive back to New York
and you've now got a gun I there is
there are gun regulations that have
never been discussed for instance a
criminal who is out of prison on parole
is not allowed to have a gun and that's
by statute the NRA doesn't tackle that
one because everybody knows what a bunch
of wackos the Republicans than the NRA
czar and they wouldn't dare go near that
one because it's just so obvious they're
criminals should not have guns the fact
is there was once a fairly jokey
explanation of how this could all be
solved and I got it over the last
Charles and we're glad to have them back
on the program
if it is even possible if you can't
regulate guns what about regulating
bullets well I think Patrick Moynihan
said we should put a a ten-thousand
percent tax on bullets as a way to
basically address since we can't do it
with guns but I just think that it's
this conversation to me is it's almost
you're in some kind of we're in a dream
world where there is some notion and a
lot of this this paranoia is that I'm
really having a gun not because I live
in a safe suburb where really what the
danger is is a raccoon in my trash can
it's that the government is going to
take over there's going to be some some
some Black Hawk helicopters coming in
and seizing me there's going to be some
kind of different tone of government
coming in and basically seizing my
property my family this is the paranoia
that just drives people to find guns and
you look at who by I'm something happens
in the city and it's 50 miles outside of
this
where people load up a lot of this is
the media a lot of it is this kind of
rabbit kind of paranoia here on
right-wing radio and it certainly is it
disingenuous to say it's not the
Republicans it is it always has been
because it's a it's a safe sweet spot
when you're running for election so
Charles just very quickly so you think
it's it's a fear it's the main reason
that people feel passionate about
holding on to guns in America it's like
it's nothing about that fear or about
their rights to do so that the fact that
it is the Second Amendment
well first off if you think about I
think that there's this wrong narrative
about everyone basically selling the
West kind of long and a rifle simply not
true
times were expensive they were hard to
maintain most people didn't have guns
it's an invention of your early 19th and
20th century that's the first point that
we didn't have them this is about
fear-mongering every single day if it
bleeds it leads you see the television
and people think oh my god I needed you
under protect my family if you have a
gun in your house you're more likely to
get yourself or somebody hurt violence
in you are to protect yourself from any
kind of home invasion or dangerous
period doctor we need to get up
Holmstrom listen good gun ownership in
America is not a privilege it is a right
and Americans like myself who owns
firearms who I'm proud to own firearms
owned them all my life of my parents are
responsible and many lives have been
saved and chaos has been prevented as a
result of this kind of ownership if you
think you can come on this show today
and skewer gun owners if you think that
anything is gonna change you know it's
not going to change it says more people
are go out and own guns give it a
situation in America and what's going on
with people who have no respect for
these locks look for lives and these
criminals but willing to kill you at the
drop of a hat you all need to wake up
and get the times that we're in if you
want to make an argument the self I had
a right to property in slavery at one
time and that was changed laws that no
longer work can be changed so to say
that this right is inalienable then
every person here
Zuka or an irritant I what you never
will
Charles Gallagher do you think anything
will change um no I know and I sadly I
do not because we have this fantasy of
this idea of what the Second Amendment
is now it's a Clint Eastwood movie
it's a Tarantino movie it has absolutely
no relevance that civilian population
should be armed with armor-piercing
bullets and we have politicians that are
simply spineless again we need to
reframe the conversation away from this
fanatical definition of the second end
of it that's wrong and put it in a pump
health perspective most Americans want
gun control it's a tiny part of the
population the NRA the lobbyists that
have hijacked the conversation and
that's our major problem
Charles Gallagher thanks very much
indeed catch up with the Sky News debate
on Apple TV Roku and on catch up and of
course on Sky News comm slash us Donald
Trump's determination has taken another
surge his lead in the polls is narrowing
but he's adamant that he's going all the
way and he's gonna win the race to the
White House well let's get some insight
now from Michael Dantonio he's a
Pulitzer Prize winning author who's just
written Donald Trump never enough
welcome to you thanks so much for
talking to us
whatever you think of his politics it's
hard to deny isn't it that Donald Trump
is live and up this a presidential race
has anything about the way he's carried
out his campaign surprised you from your
research into him not one thing you know
he's a self created man and creation
that he made is self-promotion of
marketing he's a genius at gathering
attention and his popularity now is
pretty consistent with his popularity
over the decades we've known him here in
the States for about 40 years and in all
that time he's consistently got 30%
favor
about 65% negative and that's about
where are you since today is there any
sign do you think of him running out of
steam in this campaign no I really don't
I I think that he wants to get it to the
voters so he wants their verdict and
that will start to be delivered in late
January and in February when people
actually consider who they want for
president I think up until this point
they're considering who they want to
watch on television and it's definitely
Donald Jeffrey you two were been you
would be a natural supporter of Donald
Trump will you but what do you make of
his contribution to this race is it life
and things like yeah well I pull
disclosure I know Donald I did a project
with him I like Donald a lot he's a
terrific guy I've spent time with him
and he's he's good value he really is
now I must say about Michael Dantonio
this book it's a great book and people
should read it because he spent a lot of
time going way back and explaining this
phenomenon of Brandon which is what
Donald has done now I believe something
I heard recently that life imitates high
school I really believe that Donald is
the big man on campus who is the guy
first chosen on the Saturday night dance
and the smelly gymnasium to do what we
used to call the multiplication dance
I'm dating myself terribly Carly Farina
is the Mean Girls gym teacher who
everybody hates Marco Rubio is the
too-short kid who wants to wants to run
for class dance committee chairman and
no one will vote for him and of course
Armstrong's friend ben Carson is the
class geek who got voted off the Chess
Club because he explained Cory Pesky's
variation and got it wrong
Donald is a star the others are not Jeb
Bush is nowhere and he will he will
continue and maybe even win both Iowa
and New Hampshire at that point all the
other clowns have to drop out and the
Republicans will have to make a very
serious decision do we want the the
Donald with all his baggage or do we
want a serious politician who will give
us much of the same Republican nonsense
I
Donald's in there with a real show I
don't think it can be Diller II but I
think he can beat all the others oh the
other clowns I'm strong agree with that
I mean it's really your campaign manager
for one of the other candidates for ben
Carson but do you agree that he's doing
rather well is this manager I've got the
Carson's business manager listen you
know I almost find this conversation
almost comical and entertaining because
you have two people who are admire mr.
Trump they love his entertainment value
that people are watching the debates and
there's no doubt I have tremendous
respect for mr. Trump I know mr. Trump
I've interviewed him but I actually
believe which they're not willing to
admit that mr. Trump has reached a
ceiling that is why I call it Fiorina
and Mark Rubio are continuing to surge
doctor mr. Trump is not moving up doc
mr. Trump tapped into an anger and
resentment where the voters feel they're
not represented their voice is not heard
they don't fight for them in Congress
and they want anybody but an outsider
and mr. Trump does add entertainment
value but his temperament his
willingness say whatever he wants to say
without any regards to whom he's saying
it to his attitude sometimes towards
women as it has harmed him and and the
fact that mr. Trump speaks in sound
bites and if he ever has a chance of
winning come in Costa in it win in any
of these states he has to speak with
intellectual substance this will fade
dr. Donald Trump is making way for a
serious candidate who has the capacity
to have the temperament who doesn't
appear to be a bully and combative and
while you may like the entertainment
value people watching in the end Donald
Trump if someone ever surpasses him and
takes over the lead his ego cannot
tolerate it and if he starts sliding in
the post he will drop out immediately
and don't take my word for it he said it
himself this weekend in an interview
with NBC News which tells you he's not
in foot for the long haul he's in for as
long as Donald Trump is doing well in
the polls because he feels that pose
matters
Michael Antonia dis unstrung have a
point there well you know the I think
perhaps the first thing I noted was that
Donald's ceiling is about 30 percent and
he's never been above that in this
election cycle and he's actually never
been above that in his life and he's
been the subject of polls as I said for
four decades I think given that Ben
Carson is a neurosurgeon
it's interesting to observe that
neurological experts talk about this
that got having the second highest
number of neurons and it compared with
the brain and it's far fewer but Donald
operates from the guy and he doesn't
really operate from his intellect and
then I mean Armstrong is correct that
when you ask Donald for anything deep
you can't really dig down very far
because he's not well-read most of his
positions are things that he's staked
out on a sound bite basis and he's been
repeating the same things which are
mainly xenophobia on the international
level and anger and fear on the local
level since the 1980s
way back it was the Arab oil States he
hated and the Japanese were the wily
competitors who always outfoxed us in
negotiations today it's the Chinese and
the Mexicans but it's the same dynamic
so I do agree that there is a limit to
Donald's lifespan in politics but given
the field and it's fractured quality he
could wind up at the convention either
leading and delegates are being very
substantial in his Hall and that's
something that should give GOP
Greybeards pause and Jeffery a
presumably a lot of people will be
impressed by his business success he's
also very very famous which helps him
when he tries to promote himself he's
very hard to ignore
well he's constantly promoting himself I
mean that's what he does ask Michael
what his office looks like you see a
thousand pictures
him on magazine covers Armstrong of
course is dead wrong about this when he
says that Donald will drop out as soon
as his numbers start slipping that's not
what he said an NBC News at all on the
on Meet the Press what he said was if my
numbers reached the low numbers of a
Chris Christie or George Pataki down two
percent or 0.1 they start slipping and
the fact is the others Ben and Carly and
the clown car are not surging the other
Republicans are simply slipping back
then and and and Carly are standing
about where they they have always been
the others are slipping back Donald is
slipping back a little bit but I don't
think the 30 percent ceiling now would I
vote for Donald I'm a Democrat no of
course not I'm gonna vote for Hillary
and she's gonna win and she will win no
matter who the Republicans put because
the Republicans are not serious cannabis
Donald is highly entertaining and we
live in in the era of sound bite
politics substance doesn't work anymore
if substance worked we wouldn't have had
george w bush
if substance worked we wouldn't have had
but Mitt Romney wouldn't have got the
nomination no no no no no substance is
not what it's all about its sound bites
it's coming across like imitates high
school as the big man on campus and the
one everybody wants to dance with on
Saturday night no he's a he's a star and
that's what politics has become sadly I
say but that's what politics in America
has become television so I'm struck what
do you make of that whew he's a star and
even if what you what he says you don't
like he's at least coming across as a
man of authenticity he's he's saying
what he believes in
that's how it comes over you know you
know I you cannot make Jeffery up he's
so consistent every week I did that's
why I love the brother I just got to
give it to him you can't even get upset
with the stuff that says anymore ha Elva
Donald Trump is a star he's a reality
star when it comes to the apprentice
he's a star when it comes to his
television and his real estate projects
but it's not the kind of star that the
American people are looking for in the
White House unless he can change and
show that he can become presidential
that he has the class
that he has the temperament that he
doesn't demean women that he doesn't
demean Mexican that he's not willing to
just go jab the jab with Jorge Ramos or
others like him people want to believe
that they have a commanding chief who
will not fly off the handle
who has the discipline to learn and and
and have a debate back and forth where
you don't feel you can say you're fired
or whatever else tadhana may do in a
circumstance like that look the world is
open to the nominal Trump if he's
willing to learn if he can be managed if
he can get a disciplined message I think
Donald Trump is at an age in stage in
his life where he cannot be managed he
cannot be disciplined and he will
continue along the trajectory that he's
in on and it will eventually lead to his
demise and drop into a point in the
polls where he would get out of the race
okay Michael Dantonio how far do you
think he'll go oh I think he's gonna
stay in I really do I don't think it's
in his makeup to quit unless he is
reduced to that single-digit point and I
can't imagine that he will be the
observation that we are in a media
political age is is spot-on and Donald
is the master of of that you know like
it or not we've created this monster and
and we have it and now we're gonna have
to watch it for quite a long time
okay well Michael Dantonio thanks very
much indeed for your filt and thanks as
ever to Jeffrey and to Armstrong and
that's it for this edition of the debate
you can continue watching Sky News on
Apple TV Roku and on catch up and of
course on Sky News calm until next time
goodbye
you
you